hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
you guessed it I'm back with another
compliance tip of the week this week
we're talking about cmmc control ia.l
2-3.5.2 authenticate or verify the
identities of users processes or devices
as a prerequisite to allowing access to
organizational systems imagine that you
have to actually be identified to get in
[Music]
okay
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it
cmfccontrolia.l 2-3.5.2 that's a
mouthful but a bigger mouthful is the
word authenticate that also is a
mouthful between them there's like 15
syllables there I can't even count how
many syllables that really is but it's
like two words it looks really long to
me and I'm still talking about them all
right authenticate or verify the
identities of users processes or devices
as a prerequisite to allowing access to
organizational systems this control
works to define the image of how a
system should operate when it is
compliant so again really all they're
doing is they're just sort of painting
you a picture of what it's okay to look
like if a system is going to hold cui in
order to gain access any device or user
or process should have to validate who
or what it is to gain access not just be
plugged in and magically start working
so again it's not okay to have open file
shares it's not okay to just have things
on the network that anyone could plug in
and access and that's what this control
defines now let's see what the assessors
are looking for on this one three points
of assessment they're looking for number
one
determine if the identity of each user
is authenticated or verified as a
prerequisite to system access so is it
great question I don't know uh if we
were to answer this question we might
say hey this is implemented via active
directory privileged identity management
uh or even multi-factor authentication
again you don't necessarily have to be
on a domain in order to do this
multi-factor authentication is
definitely a sign of identifying a user
assessment Point number two determine if
the identity of each user excuse me each
process acting on behalf of the user is
authenticated or verified as a
prerequisite to system access
this is implemented via active directory
privileged identity management and MFA
again same sort of mechanisms uh will
act to also authenticate the processes
now assessing Point number three
determine if the identity of each device
accessing or connecting to the system is
authenticated or verified as a
prerequisite to system access okay so
again now it's about the device system
devices accessing cui are tokenized as a
part of the multi-factor authentication
process now that's the example that we
happen to give using the idea that your
device has somehow been tokenized great
example is Office 365 GCC high again we
can help to tokenize that device as a
part of the authentication process are
there other ways to do it absolutely
right you can Define the device in a
firewall to say hey if this device isn't
recognized don't allow traffic to or
from it there's lots and lots of ways
out there but we just want to give that
that tokenization as as the example
because it's probably the most common
one out there
now if you're a defense contractor and I
know you are just like uh just like uh
just like you just like I'll screw that
one up but I'm gonna keep on rolling
because we only do these videos in one
take we don't have time for more takes
got no time for that so we'll just start
over again while I make everybody in the
background laugh all right and on call
we work with defense contractors just
like you to make incredibly terrible
jokes because that's a whole lot better
than having to figure out how you're
going to get dfar's nist itar and cmfc
compliant on your own and if you're like
me and this compliant stuff just got
dropped into your lap like a seagull on
a sunny day the good news is we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved always show you how to
leverage compliances your secret weapon
let's land more Defense work with higher
profit margins now that's what becoming
an on-call compliance hero can do for
you like I'm saving this video by doing
it in one take yes looking for more help
getting compliant our compliance experts
are always on call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now and if you love the content out here
or me saving videos from having to be
edited like 50 times well guess what you
can help us out by giving us a big
thumbs up on that like button below or
even better help us out Hulk smash that
subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliances roll it out until the next
complex it my friends stay safe and
secure out there hit us in the comments
below to let us know what you'd like to
know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]